China and Russia have been secretly
stockpiling gold at an unprecedented
rates and Vladimir Putin just unveiled
their plan to the world if this plan
works China and Russia will become
invincible remember the petrol dollar
the deal with Saudi Arabia that forced
nearly all oil rich countries in the
world to sell their oil in dollars if
they could somehow convince Saudi Arabia
to leave that deal with America and stop
selling their oil in dollars and it
would mean the end of America's reign
President Biden is bashing Saudi Arabia
that's a big mistake the U.S is furious
about opec's decision to cut oil
production President Joe Biden has
spoken of reevaluating relations with
Riyadh American lawmakers want to stop
supplying weapons to Saudi Arabia
relations between Saudi Arabia and the
United States have been strained of late
that after OPEC plus decided to slash
oil production and Washington is not
held back in its rebuke of the Kingdom
tensions between America and Saudi
Arabia escalating this week with the
White House accusing the Saudis of quote
coercing its allies to cut oil
production and side with Russia and
here's another battle that the West is
fighting a battle of narratives a battle
to win new allies only that it is
failing miserably at this first it
refused to ramp up oil production for
the European Union and now it wants to
be a part of bricks
we could be witnessing the fall of the
western-led world order right now in
front of our eyes
all centers on just one country Saudi
Arabia that's because Saudi Arabia
recently said that they were interested
in joining brics a group of five leading
economies made up of Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa and one of the
main goals of brics is to Dethrone the
dollar as the world's Reserve currency
to Dethrone America as the global
superpower and Bricks has been trying to
find ways to do this for a long time now
but none of their plans have panned outs
until now was Saudi Arabia potentially
joining their side bricks May finally
have the leverage it needs to overthrow
the dollar America and the entire
Western world order as we know it
stay dangerous and this is the coming
new world order part 2.
[Music]
and really fast if you're a creative
freelancer like a digital marketer
photographer designer or even a writer
and you want to land more clients and
make more money then you have to check
this out see typically to run your kind
of business you have to duct tape
together a bunch of pay tools like
Squarespace docusignmonday.com type for
MailChimp stripe which adds up and it
doesn't give your customers a premium
experience but that is where bloom.io
comes in see bloom.io took all these
paid tools and combined them into the
sleekest all-in-one Solution that's
gonna really impress your prospects and
it all starts with their built-in
website builder that allows visitors to
buy your services sign the contract set
up a retainer bucket time all within
Bloom and once you close a client you
can invite them to Bloom's game changing
client portal where they can chat what
you review the deliverables you uploaded
and most importantly they'll be able to
review your beautiful invoice and pay
for it right then and there with cash
out bimbo Zell PayPal and more just
think about how much you can raise your
rates when you can provide this great of
a client experience Bloom also has
powerful project management email
automation's lead management a built-in
calendar and more and the best part is
that bloom has a free tier so you're
going to be instantly saving money just
by getting to cancel all the tools you
pay for right now so go to bloom.io
jaketran with the link below to start
for free now or use code jtran for 30
off their premium features pause the
video and go to bloom.io with code Jake
tram with the link below thanks to bloom
for sponsoring this video
the Saudi royal family the house of
Assad is allegedly worth over 1.4
trillion dollars Yes you heard that
right trillion this makes them the
world's richest family where money
really is no object Lamborghini Ferrari
I thought of the general question a
Lamborghini you know I thought he was
asking me what's better what color are
you talking about me one I said black
in front of your house in three weeks I
am very sorry for this and I also makes
them one of the most powerful Bloodlines
in the world however let's not forget
the only reason the house Assad has been
able to get so rich and Powerful is
because of America America was the one
that made the sweetheart deal with them
that we talked about in part one the
petrol dollar if it wasn't for America's
protection in exchange for selling them
oil there's a real chance the house
Assad would have never been able to
ascend to such Heights unscathed America
made Saudi Arabia into what it is today
but America also made one fatal flaw in
the process it made Saudi Arabia too
rich too powerful too independent Saudi
Arabia is now so successful that it
doesn't need Daddy's credit card anymore
they have a sovereign wealth fund of
well over half a trillion dollars how do
you get from 400 billion to a trillion
over the next five years simply through
growing your assets or do you also need
significant contributions from the Saudi
government you just mentioned two of the
things that we're planning to get to the
one trillion and 70 billion dollars the
Saudi royal family can literally sit
back do nothing and they'll still make
over 30 billion dollars in interest
alone every single year how do you think
they can afford all these insane Mega
projects America made a crucial mistake
it forgot a simple yet vital law of
power you gotta keep people dependent on
you the more a person or a nation in
this case needs you the more security
and freedom you have I unfortunately
Saudi Arabia doesn't need America
anymore and America may end up paying
the ultimate price
[Music]
was never supposed to have plans for
global domination back in 2001 brick was
just an abbreviation for the four
countries but the fastest growing
economies in the world Brazil Russia
India and China South Africa only joined
in 2010 and no one really thought they'd
ever be anything more than thus until
somewhere along the lines the leaders of
the four brick countries probably
thought themselves hey we got the
fastest growing economies we want to
become more developed we also want to
stop getting bullied and enslaved by
America so why don't we work together to
make that happen
so in 2006 the leaders of each of these
four countries met for the first time
Ironically in New York and they started
game planning how they were going to
scratch each other's backs but nothing
really comes out of it until three years
later when brick makes an announcement
no one saw coming plans for a new Global
Reserve currency for Russia and China it
was an obvious move if they could remove
the dollar as the global Reserve
American sanctions and economic thus
would mean nothing America wouldn't be
able to freeze politicians bank accounts
or block them from making transactions
it would make them economically
Invincible against the west but they
wouldn't tell the rest of the world that
openly taking on the dollar would be
political suicide it might even be
literal suicide so instead they said
that they just wanted a new currency
that would be quote diverse stable and
predictable End quotes everything the
dollar wasn't and almost immediately
after their announcement the Dollar's
value unexpectedly dropped and that was
exactly what brick was hoping for if a
simple little announcement like we're
gonna try to develop a new Reserve
currency if that little thing can make
the dollar loses value maybe just maybe
they would actually have a shot at
pulling this off toppling the dollar
would be no easy feat though Reserve
currencies usually only get dethroned
after cataclysmic events like world wars
and Empires collapsing to pull this off
they would need a foolproof plan and the
perfect team
[Music]
if bricks wanted to topple America as
the global superpower they would have to
chip away at the three things that give
it all its power the IMF the World Bank
and the petrodollar for decades the IMF
and the World Bank have enforcing third
world countries into adopting Western
policies in exchange for loans we give
you debt that you'll never be able to
pay back to keep your people from
starving and for you to embezzle into
your own pocket and you be more
pro-america you let American businesses
siphon your natural resources you side
with America in the U.N it's a simple
trade-off life in exchange for Eternal
servitude so replacing the IMF and the
World Bank was first on brix's agenda
enter the new development bank or NDB
basically the World Bank bricks Edition
brix's Trojan Horse see bricks knew that
it would have to tread lightly at first
if it just came out and said hey screw
your world Bank we're coming for you
America will crush it in an instance so
instead it said it wanted to work
alongside the World Bank that it wanted
to help fund the infrastructure the
developing world so badly needed and
even though it seemed like a nice enough
idea to everyone else the brics
countries knew the truth they were
sending the NDB Behind Enemy Lines to
slowly start building up a portfolio of
their own debt slaves to slowly start
breaking down the influence the IMF and
World Bank had on the world so we were
able to step in very early to provide
both financing for the initial health
related expenditure but also to help
with economic recovery efforts so in
South Africa oh you need a loan for a
nuclear power plant why not borrow from
us so you don't end up owing the West
all that money because we've all seen
what happens when you can't pay them
back
Mexico's economic crisis deepened today
with stocks dropping sharply and the
pesos still under Fire a government
austerity plan announced yesterday and
billions of dollars in assistance from
the U.S and others apparently have not
bolstered the confidence of invested and
here in the Philippines where 44 of the
national budget is given to paying
interest charges to foreign Banks
compared with just three percent for
health services and we calculated how
much the health budget had been cut and
on the basis of that came up with a
figure that one Filipino child dies
every hour
because of the increase in debt service
payments even just by co-financing
projects with the World Bank these loans
from the new development Bank were
playing into brexit's agenda perfectly
it got people thinking that borrowing
money from the West wasn't the only
option What I Hear over and over is is
leaders in Latin America whom I know in
Korea being one of them has said Well
we'd much rather take loans and aid from
China than the United States because
they don't make these demands on us and
they've never assassinated one of our
leaders they'd never overthrown one of
our governments and they've never built
a military base on our soil and they've
never required that we sell off our our
public businesses or our utility
companies and so forth to them and
they've never asked us to keep certain
kinds of governments other countries
look at this and they say that's a very
viable model that they have there and
um maybe we should look more to that
model than the U.S model and this is
hard for me to hear I'm very patriotic
and loyal American I don't like to hear
this yeah but I understand where it's
coming from and one of the reasons I
write about these things and talk about
is because I want America to learn from
this and do better the only way we're
going to get better is by understanding
the mistakes we've made and correct them
yeah and and fight them on their own
ground you know Fight Fire with Fire but
the other thing is you know I hear
people say well if the United States is
a democracy
we don't want a democracy yeah you've
gotta you've got a dysfunctional
Congress you know they they never agree
on anything the Republicans will never
vote for any Democratic initiatives and
vice versa and you know and then during
the Trump Administration they were
saying you know you get a dysfunctional
president who who lies and you couldn't
take care of the coronavirus and so you
we hear this as we as I as I talk to
leaders in in these countries about how
China when when they you know they make
a matrix and they they make the
comparison China comes out looking
pretty good to them and who knows in the
long run what will happen I think we we
looked very good too after World War II
we did a great job of reconstructing
Europe and Asia after World War II with
the Marshall Plan and and and the World
Bank which was created to do that the
Reconstruction of these devastated
countries we did a great job we did a
great job but it during the Cold War it
kind of went crazy and by the time the
World Bank and IMF realized what was
happening it was already too late and to
make matters worse just a few years
later china hit them with a sucker punch
the belt and Road initiative or Bri
according to China the bra was only
supposed to promote trade between China
and the developing world but in every
way that counts the Bri works just like
the IMF and World Bank China gives
expensive loans to developing countries
and in exchange they get to influence
the country's economy and governments
any country where they go in and you're
quite correct that they go in and they
bring in their own Workforce as they
bring in their own engineering companies
and they use resources collateral just
as we did I think as as the Russian
economic Hitman told me I I think that
China's learned from that at the same
time their their goals seem to be pretty
much the same get the resources that you
can get employment for your your
companies and your workers and so they
they're doing kind of the same thing but
they're they're not making the same uh
conditions the NDB and Bri leveled the
playing field it loosened the Chokehold
America had on developing countries
which left just one last Target on
Bruce's Hit List the petrol dollar but
America has had oil producing countries
in a death grip since the 70s so if
something were to top of the petrodollar
it would have to be something huge
something totally unexpected but luckily
bricks didn't have to wait too long for
the perfect opportunity to come around
for more than 40 years Saudi Arabia and
America's little mutually beneficial
relationship worth perfectly Saudi
Arabia commits insane human rights
violations America looks the other way
America invades Middle Eastern countries
and causes absolute chaos Saudi Arabia
also looks the other way it was the
ultimate money-making system until the
murder of Jamal khashoggi a Saudi
Arabian journalist who criticized the
country's leadership he was brutally
executed in a Saudi Consulate in Turkey
in 2018 and the order came directly from
the prince himself
for more than two weeks the Saudis
insisted nothing untoward happened in
this building the Jamal khashoggi walked
in and walked out again alive now this
an admission the journalist is in fact
dead and the Saudis killed him
it was something that Saudi Arabia has
ordered dozens of times before see an
annoying journalists order them to be
killed nothing new but for some
inexplicable reason Americans couldn't
let this one go they actually cared and
suddenly the American masses were
expecting their government to actually
go out and do something about it imagine
that so when Joe Biden started
campaigning for president he did what
anyone else would do in his position he
appealed to the masses he promised
America that he would hold Saudi Arabia
in its Crown Prince accountable for the
murder of Jamal khashoggi Mr Vice
President the CIA has concluded that the
leader of Saudi Arabia directed the
murder of us-based journalist Jamal
khashoggi the state department also says
the Saudi government is responsible for
executing non-violent offenders and for
torture president Trump has not punished
senior Saudi leaders would you yes and I
said it at the time
khashoggi was in fact murdered and
dismembered and I believe in the order
of the Crown Prince and I would make it
very clear we were not going to in fact
sell more weapons to them he even went
so far as the cause Saudi Arabia a
pariah States we were going to in fact
make them pay the price and make them in
fact the Pariah that they are there's
very little social redeeming value of
the in the present government in Saudi
Arabia and then he became presidents
which complicated things turns out
President Biden didn't like the idea of
turning America's strongest Middle
Eastern Ally into an enemy he also
didn't want to lose out on all that
sweet oil said he was selling either so
he did a quick 180 and said that the
crown press should actually be given
immunity from any investigations into
khashoggi's death now the Biden
Administration has given Saudi Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman immunity from
a lawsuit over the murder of Jamal
khashoggi and he just prayed that no one
will remember that pesky little campaign
promise he made unfortunately for Biden
the Saudis aren't that quick to forget
and remember Saudi Arabia is no longer
America's female dog anymore they are
doing perfectly fine by themselves and
it would be something that would come
back to haunt Biden much sooner than he
bargained for
February 2022 Russia invades Ukraine
from the Ukrainian Capital Kiev gunfire
and explosions have been heard here and
in the Second City of kharkiv shortly
after the Russian President Vladimir
Putin authorized a special military
operation in Ukraine's donbass region
and all of a sudden the second biggest
exporter of oil in the world suddenly
gets left with massive sanctions which
means no more Russian oil and with less
oil on the market prices skyrocketed in
America gas prices jumped up to more
than five dollars a gallon and suddenly
the American government was having
flashbacks that a 1973 oil crisis
luckily there was a simple solution rate
all America had to do to lower oil
prices was go to Saudi Arabia and asked
them to produce more oil except Biden
have forgotten just how angry he made
Saudi Arabia with as little make them
pay campaign promise so when America
came crawling on their knees to Saudi
Arabia Saudi Arabia flat out refused to
make more oil even worse they actually
decided to cut their oil production the
further prices at the pump could Spike
again after Wednesday OPEC some of the
world's leading oil producers announced
plans to slash their supply
disappointment and we're looking at what
alternatives you may have after weeks of
celebrating fall and gas prices it's
back to the drawing board for the Biden
Administration to stay focused on making
sure that we continue to keep the pain
at the pump as minimal as possible White
House spokesperson John Kirby says the
U.S must now figure out how to make up
for the lack of oil OPEC says it'll be
cutting back 2 million barrels a day
starting next month providing security
stability to the energy Market we
believe that this was a short-sighted
decision so America did the most
diplomatic thing it could think of it
accused Saudi Arabia of siding with the
Russians well we believe by uh by the
decision that OPEC plus made last week
there certainly are aligning themselves
with Russia real smooth but it didn't
end there no no no President Biden
wasn't done rattling up the Saudis Jets
no heat turned that there would be
consequences for Saudi refusing to play
ball which led to this
year
anybody the challenges the existence of
this country and this Kingdom
all of us we are projects
and martyrdom that's my message to
anybody that thinks that you can
threaten us it was the last straw the
Saudis have had enough daddy's little
girl had already siphoned off as much
money as she could into her own bank
account and now it was time to drive off
in Daddy's Rolls Royce leaving daddy in
the dust
even Old Friends of the West are
ditching it like Saudi Arabia it wants
to be a part of brics if Saudi Arabia
joins brics and the dollar continues
collapsing in value there would be a
real chance of toppling the dollar with
whatever currency brics comes up with
and if that happens Saudi Arabia was
switched from selling oil in dollars to
selling oil in that new currency if
Saudi Arabia does that other oil
producing countries will soon follow and
if that happens if the petrol dollar is
no more America will find themselves in
the same position as it has other
countries in right now if the petrol
dollar is no more and America wanted to
stay alive and not collapse they would
have to use their dollars to buy this
new brics currency to then use that
brics currency to buy their precious oil
no more printing money out than there to
meet their energy needs it would be a
nail in the coffin for America why
because America doesn't produce anything
America doesn't make anything so what
would America be able to sell to other
countries to get their hands on this
British currency to buy oil nothing
America would simply have to take on
more debt except this time the debt
won't be in their own currency that they
can just print more of they would
actually have to pay it back instead of
just being able to print their way out
of it if the dollar is dethroned America
would actually have to experience the
full brunt of their money printing
because now other countries wouldn't be
holding so many dollars so the only
dollars America would inflate from their
money printing would be their own no
matter how you slice it if the dollar is
toppled America is done this reality is
still a ways away but bricks is gaining
steam because it's not just societies
who want to join bricks I ran turkey
Egypt Argentina at the UAE these are
just some of the dozen or so countries
that have recently become interested in
becoming brics members if they do join
the brics alliance brics would have a
GDP 30 bigger than America they would be
in control of 60 of the world's gas
reserves and they will rule over one of
fifty percent of the world's population
Revolution is in the air a new world
order is in the air and this time it
might not be an American one
the dollar becoming the reserve currency
then evolving into the petrol dollar all
of this is what allowed America to
conquer the entire world America is the
modern day Roman Empire the Empire where
the Sun never sets the Roman Empire was
completely dependent on slave labor
slave labor was the Bedrock of all their
wealth and power without slave labor the
society would have just stopped
functioning fast forward to today and
many people naively think slavery went
away but that's just simply not true
slavery never went away it just changed
forms right underneath our noses but
instead of violence instead of coercion
instead of whips and chains America
found a new way to enslave the entire
world much more efficiently through
financial means getting countries to
accept the dollar getting countries to
become indebted to America getting all
the poor countries to stay in poverty
doing all the hard labor while America
gets to sit back and enjoy its spoils
and the crazy thing is if you look at
all the billionaires if you look at all
the biggest corporations in the world
you'll notice that they also use
Financial slavery to get their weather
at see in general it's extremely hard to
become a billionaire unless you either
one get really good at tricking
investors into giving you a lot of money
or two you get really good at employing
some kind of modern day slave labor
think about it it's just simply not
possible for Apple to produce the iPhone
at a reasonable price if it wasn't for
the de facto slaves in China and if you
also want unimaginable amounts of money
and power you have to get really good at
this game of financial slavery just like
America and the biggest corporations did
Financial slavery is the secrets the
secret that everyone is too afraid or
too ignorant to say out loud and when I
realized all this after researching all
these videos over the past few years I
knew I had to share with you guys so I
put all my findings into my greatest
body of work yets Financial slavery
Master Class 20 plus lessons all
narrated by me in the same binge-worthy
documentary style you're watching right
now where I break down everything you
need to know about financial slavery how
it came about how America exploited it
how so many billionaires and
corporations employ it but most
importantly we break down the simplest
way for you to start employing it for
yourself what without being as evil as
they are so scroll down and click the
link below to watch the first lesson of
the masterclass for free right now this
is an education that is unlike anything
you're going to find anywhere else no
teacher no University no MBA that costs
tens of thousands of dollars a year will
teach you any of this and it's not gonna
cost you thousands of dollars or even a
thousand dollars like the average
college course costs it's only gonna
cost a tiny fraction of that and on top
of that I wanted this to be a chest for
you to make money right away too that's
why on top of getting to learn the
secret you're also going to be able to
earn around a hundred dollars for every
person you refer to the master class but
that is not the special part the special
part is that just like Andrew Tates
Hustler's University affiliate program
where some Affiliates were making up
worth of 11 000 a week from just posting
clips of Tates I will also provide you
with step-by-step instructions just like
Tate did on how to take clips of my
videos edit them into tick tocks and
YouTube shorts so that you too can go
viral and get sales Tate only paid his
Affiliates 25 per sign up but we're
gonna pay you four times that at around
a hundred dollars so scroll down and
click the link below to buy now
foreign
[Music]